hello hello hello my friends we have the
incomparable sochi gomez here with us
tonight i'm so excited to see you you
look absolutely phenomenal
i need to know i need to know what is
your favorite part about your character
and what can we expect from her when
seeing the movie
well i can't say too much especially
because kevin's like right there
but what i can say is i am very excited
for the movie to come out and
i'm just really excited for people to
see
my work on screen i mean i put so much
work into it and i'm really really so
proud of it and i'm just excited for it
to come out i'm just excited to be here
number one like i'm such a fan
of marvel in general so being here is
just like i'm like shaking just being
here like being invited i'm like yes
well now you're part of the mcu family
what is it like seeing familiar faces
and being part of this awesome family
well number one it's just weird to be
like these are familiar faces like that
number one is just crazy um but i mean
i'm just so lucky to be here and
to be considered as a part of the family
is just
fans i i love when fans of the mcu
become people within the mcu i think
that's the best way to do it because it
becomes so authentic i know we can't
know much about your character but you
have to tell us about some of your
favorite moments while filming this
going to
craft which is like the stand where you
get all your food
that okay it has like nothing to do with
my acting or being on set but it's one
of my favorite places to be i get to
just like i'm i'm a huge fan of veggies
so i'm just like
jesus
i'm i mean just you not me or oreos are
pretty good too oreos are pretty good
too so you're about to see marvel studio
shangshi in the legends of the ten rings
how excited for you to see this film i
am pretty dang excited i mean i'm going
to be honest i am really excited to see
aquafina she is so funny and i've been a
fan of her for so long and i'm just
really pumped